the doctor said to me Lindsay you're
gonna need to watch out for signs of
rabies but you're apparently increased
irritation bombing at the mouth and
extreme anger I was like Doc I'm pretty
sure I've had rabies since I was four
years old
her comedy is described as take no
prisoners it is a lot of fun she will
skewer everyone everything but in a good
way and she is performing at the Wise
Guys Comedy Club next week welcome
Lindsey Glaser back to the show thank
you so much for being here thank you for
having me so excited for you because
you've been doing great you sold out the
last time you're expected to sell out
again and this is not necessarily how
you started as far as a career is
concerned you were an attorney I was
technically I am still an attorney but
it's the same skill it's performance all
jobs are a sales job
you do it well I mentioned that you
skewer everything everybody but you uh
walk that fine line that make comedians
really funny in that it's not over the
top mean spirited
some people would say it's not over the
top mean spirited maybe not for daytime
TV well you are the alpha B yes right we
won't say here but you're the alphabet
yeah so you do have an edge to you and
people should know that going in but
much like Don Rickles was able to skewer
people and let them know at the same
time okay it's still okay you know
things are okay that's right we only
roast the ones we love right right have
you have uh gotten a lot of your comedy
from your daughter who's now nine years
old right yes she's nine years old she's
a firecracker as they would say she got
in trouble last week and I told her I
don't like you or your behavior very
much and she yelled at me it's not my
job to make you like me it's my job to
like myself there's too much wisdom in
that that's scary I was like angry and
proud at the same time well now you seem
likable to me we had a chance to talk
ahead of time but your daughter uh has a
friend who thinks otherwise right she
told me after I said that to her that
this is why my imaginary friend doesn't
like you I said excuse me and she said
yeah she thinks you're too self-absorbed
and I said your imaginary friend that
you made up the excitement self-absorbed
she said vain yes in vain and possibly
bipolar that's fantastic all right but
Kendall I asked her I said hey out of
curiosity what's your imaginary friend's
name she said Grandma
[Laughter]
you were in the public Spotlight for a
bizarre reason oh that's right yeah
Scottie Pippen went after you he did
Scottie Pippen sued me I lived in this
house my house was ruined in a hurricane
in Florida uh Scottie Pippen sued me
because he thought I was related to
Malcolm Glazer who the former passed
away owner of the Tampa Bay Bucs thought
you had billions of dollars instead of
yeah whatever instead of you know fives
and ten exactly yeah exactly how did
that end or how did it come to a
conclusion well how it ended was Scottie
Pippen tried to get me to send sign an
NDA saying I want to talk about it so he
could go on TV and talk about the last
dance and his book settling scores if
you come to the show you'll see how he
did it I'll tell you all about it oh my
gosh that's great we do want to tell
people about where the show is and we
also want to tell people that you have a
place in your heart for military and
there's a special deal for them at your
show yeah that's right if you are
military and you can prove it your first
drink is on us the show is actually at
Wiseguys Comedy Club located in the arts
district it's 1511 South Main Street you
can get your tickets by going to the
website which is
vegas.wiseguys.com all right let's
review that again Lindsay thanks for
joining us she is going to be at Wise
Guys comedy club that's the 16th and
17th of this month and you can go to
vegas.wiseguyscomedy.com right that's
right and they do have the special offer
that we talked about if you're in the
mail military and can prove it you get
your first drink for free Lindsay it's
always fun to have you here thank you so
much thanks so much all right